[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça vient Villedieu merci d'être là
délégué syndical
voilà ça se passe très bien ou alors on
parle de on a parlé plein de choses
ensemble notamment quand il y avait eu
la la grève de la SNCF pourquoi vous
êtes introduit chez evlma LVMH en fait
c'était quoi c'était le symbole oui en
fait c'était une action médiatique
symbolique et pacifique je dis il y a
pas eu de casse hein contrairement à ce
qu'on entend j'ai entendu à droite et à
gauche le but c'était un fait de passer
un message parce qu'on a un président de
la République qui nous dit de toute
façon la seule solution pour régler le
problème des retraites c'est faire
travailler les gens deux ans de plus y
compris tous les gens qui ont des qui
ont des carrières pénibles et ben nous
on lui propose une idée voilà l'idée
c'est tout simplement pourquoi pas taxer
ceux qui sont les plus riches les
milliardaires alors on a choisi LVMH ça
aurait pu être quelqu'un d'autre voilà
LVMH 80 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
14 milliards de bénéfices rien qu'en
2022 voilà donc nous on n'est pas pour
tourner plutôt sympa on n'est pas pour
tout prendre mais on se dit est-ce
changerait pas imaginons on est
complètement fou pas une petite
possibilité de financement dans ces
milliards de bénéfices les entreprises
du CAC 40 c'est à dire les 40 plus
grandes entreprises de France c'est 152
milliards de bénéfices en 2022 donc
est-ce que ça serait pas possible de
taper un peu là-dedans pour financer
notre système de retraite au lieu
d'obliger l'ensemble des salariés de
France de leur voler parce que c'est ça
derrière la réforme des retraites c'est
leur voler leurs deux meilleurs années
de retraite parce que les deux années
vous êtes le plus en forme c'est les
deux premières années de retraite donc
si vous décalez fait l'avocat du diable
Fabien les gens ils vont dire les
personnes qui font des bénéfices et qui
font travailler de nombreuses personnes
qui font voilà des créneaux ils vont
dire mais nous c'est pas c'est pas notre
problème c'est c'est pas c'est c'est le
problème de l'État ils vont vous dire ça
leur place ils vont vous dire bah nous
on a des entreprises à la limite à la
limite je vous dis ça bien à la limite
que comme j'avais dit la dernière fois
on crée peut-être sur deux ans super
impôts exceptionnel je te dis n'importe
quoi tu vois super impôt exceptionnel si
quelqu'un déjà d'accord tu vois
peut-être pour aider les plus démunis
parce qu'ils en ont extrêmement besoin
et ça je suis complètement d'accord
peut-être voilà faire un super impôt
exceptionnel ou deux ans sur le relais
les plis et ceux qui super ceux qui sont
les plus aisés ça je suis d'accord mais
là en fait c'est que les mecs vont dire
ils vont dire mais nous on n'est pas
nous on est pas responsable en fait nous
nous on veut peut-être même pas là on
veut la veut pas la retraite à cet
âge-là on veut peut-être ils sont
peut-être contre la retraite la question
peut-être que les les salariés dès le
démarrage et le patron d'élevéh il est
il est contre la réforme des retraites
et derrière votre symbolique il y a
quand même une idéologie parce que
est-ce que vous avez demandé leur avis
aux caissières aux vendeuses et tout ça
qui sont très content de travailler dans
ces groupes qui gagnent bien leur vie
qui ont des intéressement et après tout
enfin pourquoi elle est sanctionnée par
par cette par ce discours en fait on
fonctionne personne je pense que les
caissières elles ont pas du tout envie
de bosser jusqu'à 64 ans et aujourd'hui
tous les instituts sont sondages le
disent les salariés les salariés de lvms
salariés étaient pas content que les
salariés les France a 90%
cette réforme des retraites nous la
seule chose qu'on veut qu'on veut
expliquer plutôt timidement et et
gentiment c'est que on nous explique
qu'il y a pas d'argent pour financer les
caisses de retraite donc nous on lève le
petit doigt si on lève le petit doigt
n'est pas écouté donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on fait une action symbolique en
disant bah si il y a de l'argent et il y
a de l'argent à foison et il y a des
gens qui ont un pognon de dingue en
France quand vous faites 150 milliards
de bénéfices pour 38 parce qu'on dit le
CAC 40 mais en fait c'est 38 entreprises
il y en a encore deux qui ont pas encore
publié leur compte donc sur ces 38
entreprises 150 milliards de de
bénéfices ça c'est c'est à dire la
moitié du budget de de la moitié du
budget des retraites est-ce que ça
serait pas possible est-ce que ça serait
pas possible de taper un peu là-dedans
pour éviter que justement les caissières
ne se retrouvent pas et je peux vous
dire que les caissières elles ont pas du
tout envie de bosser jusqu'à 64 ans mais
moi Fabien je vais te dire moi ce que je
pense aussi c'est qu'avant tout il faut
aider les entreprises et que justement
en aidant les entreprises pour récupérer
justement cet argent dont tu parles pour
peut-être financer les retraites ça moi
je pense que c'est ça je pense aussi que
le gouvernement faudrait que le
gouvernement laisse les personnes qui
créent des richesses que on en crée
encore plus qu'on aide vraiment les
chefs d'entreprise et les entreprises
mais que derrière il leur disent et oh
les gars on vous a aidé il faut
maintenant nous redonner voilà ce qu'on
a fait pour vous et que derrière on
puisse faire une caisse spéciale voilà
je te dis pour aider comme tu dis pour
aider à vraiment à financer les
retraites et moi je pense aussi au plus
démunis et je te le dis va bien moi
j'envoie tous les jours les gens dans la
rue viennent me voir ils me dis Cyril on
en peut plus on est on travaille je te
dis je le dis à chaque fois on travaille
de 8h du matin à 19h le soir on a même
pas de quoi acheter un à manger à nos
enfants faut pas donc on travaille tous
les jours on nous a toujours dit quand
on était petit si tu travailles tu vas
pouvoir avoir une belle vie au travail
on se bat mais on est comme des cons le
15 du mois je suis obligé de dire à ma
fille non je peux pas ce soir je vais là
je on va être obligé de manger du pain
et de l'eau c'était n'importe quoi mais
c'est vrai et aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'il y a c'est ça qu'il faudrait faire
je pense qu'aujourd'hui même les
entreprises je te parle des PME tout ça
elles sont étranglés donc aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que un moment il faut il faut
il faut s'occuper de ça aussi mais je
vois ce que tu veux dire Fabien je
comprends tout à fait franchement je
comprends tout à fait ce que tu veux
dire mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'est grand chef d'entreprise vont dire
mais non créer des des milliers
d'emplois et aujourd'hui c'est que nous
ne sommes pas les responsables oui j'ai
moi je comprends tout à fait la force du
symbole mais effectivement est-ce que
vous ne vous trompez pas de cible ah oui
vous étiez où il y a 15 jours chez un
gestionnaire de fonds gigantesque là
dans le deuxième arrondissement de Paris
là c'est une entreprise privée je vous
incite pas à aller dans un ministère
parce qu'ils sont protégés mais est-ce
que c'est pas un peu tapé à côté les
vrais problèmes là est-ce qu'il faut pas
vraiment ne pas s'en prendre aux
édifices publics mais alerter l'État en
tant que puissance vous allez me dire
vous le faites il vous répond pas mais
là on est un peu à côté je trouve
justement cette action c'est pour dire
effectivement vous avez raison ou ceux
qui décident des cotisations sociales et
des il faut c'est l'état mais c'est une
action justement c'est un petit clin
d'oeil qu'on fait un Mâcon Macron nous
explique bah j'ai pas de solution pour
résoudre les problèmes des retraites et
ben nous on en trouve une voilà et
effectivement LVMH c'est symbolique
pourquoi c'est symbolique parce que
voilà c'est Bernard Arnault Bernard
Arnault c'est la première richesse du
monde ça va de la France du monde
d'accord
ce que vous dites moi ça me révolte
effectivement de voir la pauvreté y
compris qui est en France bien sûr et
quand vous voyez cette pauvreté là et
que vous voyez de l'autre bout de
l'échiquier une richesse de dingue et
ben peut-être qu'est-ce qui irait pas
dire je comprends qu'il devrait y avoir
je comprends tout à fait comment ce que
tu dis mais Bernard Arnault et plein de
il donne énormément au-delà des impôts
et 25 millions d'impôts mais je sais que
nous il donne dans un pour énormément
d'associations il a énormément durant il
a fait beaucoup de climatisation fiscale
aussi mais je te dis après il y a je te
parle voilà c'est un exemple mais je te
parle même de tous les milliardaires
mais je comprends ce que tu veux dire et
que je comprends tout à fait je te jure
ce que tu veux dire et Fabien et je vais
par exemple j'en ai parlé ici aussi mais
je pense peut-être qu'il faudrait
instaurer je te dis limite que et plus
riche peut-être aide l'état pendant un
ou deux ans pour vos mêmes cinq ans pour
essayer de de de devenir de subvenir aux
besoins de ceux qui n'ont plus besoin et
que peut-être l'État devrait mettre je
te dis je sais pas un super impôts un
truc un un une taxe spéciale
contribution exception
tous ces gens-là comme on va faire et il
y a dicton qui dit quand le quand le
quand le gros maigri le maigreur donc
c'est ça le problème
si on déséquilibre toute la pyramide et
je comprends très bien votre discours
mais comme pour le coup ils font ils
sont en France ils font des efforts et
puis des impôts donc ils sont essentiels
pour le la bonne marche du pays même si
un énorme décalage on est tous d'accord
et je rajouterais si je peux me dire
c'est une question monsieur c'est qu'en
fait on parle souvent des impôts qui
sont payés par les riches ou pas on
parle pas aussi des charges sociales il
faut savoir quand c'est ça un Bérard
Renault
1000 euros à quelqu'un de salaire c'est
750 euros dans la poche du salarié il
paye 600 ou 700 € de charge tout ça ça
paye quoi ces charges sociales énorme en
France elles sont considérables en
France sur le sur le salariat les
charges sociales vous le savez vous
défendrez pas les patrons et je
comprends votre positionnement mais il
faut le dire il faut le rappeler parce
que c'est important et à en tout cas ça
sert cet argent à payer les écoles qui
sont gratuites en France qui est pas le
cas dans plein de pays du monde
l'éducation qui est gratuite en France
j'ai pas le cas dans beaucoup de pays du
monde faut juste un peu le rappeler de
temps en temps quoi voilà
les entreprises payent des cotisations
sociales c'est tout à fait normal et
c'est parce qu'elle paye des cotisations
sociales qu'aujourd'hui nous avons le
meilleur système de retraite au monde et
cocorico il faut le défendre et c'est ce
qu'on fait depuis trois mois c'est juste
d'ailleurs ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a énormément de de
baisse de cotisations sociales et baisse
de cotisation sociale c'est 200
milliards d'euros par an voilà donc
aussi ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que derrière toutes ces baisses de
cotisation sociale c'est de l'argent au
moins pour la sécu pour les retraites
donc d'un côté il nous explique on
baisse les cotisations je suis pas sûr
pour faire énormément d'embauche et de
l'autre côté ils disent bah il y a plus
d'argent dans les caisses donc est-ce
que je fais et ben je décale l'âge de la
retraite à 64 ans donc nous justement on
veut essayer de dire il y a des pistes
on serait effectivement dans une
situation où la France coulerait sous
les elle serait pauvres voilà il y
aurait pas de richesse mais aujourd'hui
une richesse de dingue enfin faut se
rendre compte il y a une richesse de
dingue en France et on nous dit il y a
pas d'argent pour alimenter la sécurité
sociale il y a pas d'argent pour nos
retraites et il y a cette richesse de
dingue et il y a pas de bol c'est que en
fait la réforme des retraites elle est
tombée au mois de février et le mois de
février c'est le mois où tous les
entreprises font déclare leur bénéfices
de l'année 2022 et d'un côté où nous a
expliqué il y a pas d'argent pour
financer les retraites et de l'autre
côté tous les jours tous les jours il y
avait un gros groupe qui disait allez
total 19 milliards de bénéfices LVMH 14
milliards donc à un moment donné les
gens ça les rend dingue ils disent mais
comment c'est possible comment c'est
possible qu'on nous explique qu'il faut
serrer la ceinture bosser deux ans plus
enfin derrière tout ça moi je fais ça je
fais pas ça pour le plaisir moi je fais
ça justement parce que derrière ce
décalage de 62 à 64 ans il y a
énormément de souffrance il y a des gens
qui ont pas plus il y a des caissières
il y a des gens dans le bâtiment qui
n'en peux plus de bosser et qui
aujourd'hui n'arrive même pas à se
projeter à 62 ans et on va leur
expliquer bah non tu vas couler une
dalle tu vas aller bosser sur un toit tu
as bossé sur un écha faudage à 64 ans
aux gens qui sur les réseaux disent
c'est du racisme anti-riche
moi je suis pas raciste après demander
aux riches qui mettent un peu la main à
la poche je trouve ça tout à fait normal
je te jure le Conseil mmh et on a
quelques fois c'était 5 milliards par an
pareil pour les footballeurs
vous contribuer bien sûr ça payer les
retraites pourquoi pas
de problème les animateurs aussi bien
sûr
les animateurs
je le dis j'ai une tendresse vraiment
pour Fabien tiens gars qui nous explique
toujours très bien les choses et je vous
jure si le gouvernement recevait des
gars comme Fabien quel est leur
expliquer je suis sûr qu'on trouverait
des solutions assez vite je vous jure
que c'est vrai Fabien et plein de gars
que je à qui je parle dans les rues ils
ont un discours qui est très intéressant
ils ont plein d'idées et mine de rien
ils sont pas là pour [__] la merde ils
veulent juste s'en sortir ils veulent
juste ils parlent au nom de plein de
Français qui sont dans la merde et ils
essaient voilà d'être un peu le voilà
d'être le porte-parole de de certains
Français qui ont pas accès qui viennent
pas dans les médias etc et qui sont pas
dans la rue et je vous jure que s'il y
avait un peu plus de dialogue je pense
que ça on trouverait beaucoup plus de
solutions illégales comme Fabien il y en
a plein des gars qui ont des normes et
c'est vrai qui parle bien qui
s'expriment bien qui est pas là pour
[__] la merde qui est juste là pour
s'en sortir et pour aider certaines
personnes qui qui s'en sortent pas oui
non juste une deuxième question Fabien
pardon mais comment on parle aussi peu
de ça comment tu expliques quand vous
expliquez pardon comment vous expliquer
que la France connaissait l'âge de la
retraite l'Espagne vous connaissez l'âge
de la retraite le Portugal vous
connaissez l'âge de la retraite 67 ans
dans ces pays-là la France est le pays
où on part le plus tard l'Italie n'en
parlons pas comment vous expliquer dans
tous ces pays je pense Portugal comme
billet que je connais bien par exemple
l'Italie également il y a pas eu un pet
de mouvement social les gens ont été
plutôt d'accord parce qu'ils ont compris
la logique économique de tout ça
pourquoi en France alors qu'on vise on
travaille à 67 ans en Espagne au
Portugal pourquoi en France ça passe si
mal c'est une vraie question eh ben
parce qu'on est en France attaché à
notre modèle social et parce qu'on se
bat parce qu'il y a eu des grèves de 95
les graines de 2010 et qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y a une réforme des retraites il y
a des millions de gens dans la rue il y
a des syndicalistes qui viennent de
temps en temps ici pour expliquer ben
non non il y a pas de fatalité non il y
a de l'argent il y en a partout et je
peux vous dire que partout en Europe les
gens au Portugal en Espagne ils nous
disent mais on est un modèle en France
une limite tenez nous on s'est fait
avoir on s'est fait avoir sur la somme
des retraites continuer tenez ne vous
faites pas avoir comme nous